bang bang guys
what's up lunch money time on a thursday
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
20 minutes or less little information a
little laugh
the beautiful and intelligent planet
marinova or today
uh they'll want to be kylie jenner we
are ready to
rock and roll i got the kylie lipstick
she's a kylie lipstick on she's got a
kylie outfit on
which it looks like the outfit this is a
this is a jumpsuit
a jumpsuit we're jumping i don't know
where we're jumping but we're jumping
let's jump
off and get started what's going on with
unemployment bad jokes
um three more million americans file for
unemployment benefits
i mean this is now 36.5 million
first-time claimants since mid-march
so the last two months over 36 million
americans to file for unemployment last
week
2.98 million again uh
look i wrote in march uh something that
said we are headed towards
unemployment that is going to be worse
than the great depression
and people were literally yelling at me
saying stop fear-mongering
well i thought i was gonna take i was
those people i thought i thought it was
gonna take until q3 to happen it
happened in
eight weeks here we are we now have
36 million americans who have filed for
unemployment claims
that is literally more than one fifth
more than twenty percent
of the entire american workforce how it
says economists say this is relatively
good news because it means things aren't
getting
worse yeah the numbers are going down
but it's still
net positive every single week i think
that we're going to continue to see a
million americans filing for
unemployment every week
possibly through the end of june and
we're so desensitized to the numbers if
you remember
the most that we had ever seen in
unemployment in a single week i think
was 700
000 unemployment claims in 1982
right and we we hadn't seen hundreds of
thousands like that in a very long time
and then all of a sudden we saw 6.6
million and now we see oh
only 3 million like we're doing well and
you gotta remember it's just eight weeks
ago that would have been an unfathomable
number
uh but now all of a sudden here we are
yeah
so uh the other day this is kind of
random but uh
i watched this video where i interviewed
a i won't say who but like a hot startup
founder
um who was raising so many so much money
from vcs
and i asked him what are you gonna do
in a time if the market turns suddenly
and
he said yeah but the market doesn't
really turn suddenly like
every time anytime there's a recession
or anything like that economic downturn
it takes a while for that to happen it
doesn't just happen right away
and i was thinking like wow wonder what
he's doing now bang bang [ __ ] happens
fast coming at you
right in an eight week period by the way
the solution to unemployment
open up the economy and get back to work
we'll continue to say it until they do
it
open up the economy let people go back
to work stop the madness okay
do it safely but do it ebitda
c ebitda c what is ebitda stand for do
you know
without looking at it oh yes what is it
um god what the hell
was the oh earnings uh before
oh earnings before interest taxes
uh hold on hold on hold on what was the
d what was the d
debt no you can't you can't say what
what is the d on the internet
wait why because that'll lead to bad
jokes oh no i don't like that
what is the d stand for uh depreciation
depreciation in
immortalization amateurization whatever
so earnings before interest
taxes depreciation and amortization
that is a financial calculation it
basically helps you understand
what is a company making now this is a
very manipulatable number
because i can depreciate assets faster
or slower
i can do all sorts of different things
there uh and so
now all of a sudden people are putting
ebitda c
as one of their financial metrics i mean
why not at this point well what's the c
stand for it says we're coronavirus
literally these people
wait again no do it again that's the
nicki minaj yeah dude again coronavirus
corona virus that was not called
corona virus so it's
earnings before interest taxes
depreciation amortization and
coronavirus
this is complete madness so here's the
problem is during bad times people do
bad [ __ ] they're usually good people but
they have no other choice they're
they're backed into a corner they gotta
make
uh they do things that they just
normally wouldn't do out of necessity
it's kind of funny and not funny but
like it it's kind of like
well if i had done that i would have
earned this much money like
this company called schneck process
shank process
a german manufacturing group added back
5.4 million
euros of first quarter profits that it
said it would have made
were not for the hit caused by yeah this
is [ __ ] garbage right i mean like
literally this is madness right and
just so again this is how you know we'll
always be real with you guys
this is madness it's like saying uh oh i
would have made more money
if they didn't have the construction
down the street and stop the foot
traffic or
oh we would have made more money if that
hurricane didn't happen or oh we would
have made more money if our supplier had
given us enough supplies
that's probably true right it's just how
do they know how much they would have
made
no it but that life happens you can't
you can't say
we would have made more money if and i
don't care what you say after that and
including your financial projections you
didn't make the money
right you're you're literally here's the
um the absolute cynic in me says
they're lying okay but maybe they're
lying that's what they're doing they're
they're putting a project they're
putting a number out there that's not
true you didn't make that money how do
you say that you made the money if you
didn't actually make that
they're saying what they think they
would have made but my
my point is don't you think that they're
just
kind of telling investors like hey you
can expect this from us when there's not
a mandated
shutdown again it's like saying oh uh
here's what our financial performance
was before the hurricane hit
and when we go back we're going to do
the same thing how do you know
you don't know that yeah do you think
that there is going to be the same
economic activity that was pre pandemic
i don't do you think that this business
is going to have the same
customers probably not like again it
goes back to
just like in times of crisis when a
government can overreach and try to take
personal
uh freedoms or civil liberties what
we're seeing right now is accountants
auditors and companies they're going to
try to get away with whatever they can
and somebody's got to put their foot
down and say this is absolute nonsense
i like i like how someone said it's a
bit ironic to say we're adding back the
effects of coronavirus to deal with the
effect of coronavirus
when you're looking at coronavirus these
revenues will never come back it is
literally a fiction
yeah exactly oh shocking somebody else
thinks that literally these people are
lying
it is no they're lying and it's
important to call it that way
the words that are used in these times
are really important right i tell a joke
all the time about
she's pinching me right now trying to
get me to shut up but i'm not going to
shut up
the whole thing is the words you use
really really matter so i always tell
the example of
yes the line has legal implications so
you don't want to
they are lying again and i think that i
think that they should legally be held
accountable for that you if you are a
publicly traded company and you come out
to shareholders and say
ebitda c here's the money we would have
made right
okay you can't say that i get you i hear
you okay
um go ahead
are you sad yeah i just i i think that
people
always they say oh it's not a big deal
and they push it aside it's a big
deal but the reason why it's important
is because what they are doing again
in the article it says it is fiction
they are lying and here's what ends up
happening how do you define
pre-chronovirus
so should all of a sudden movie theaters
say hey in the third week of march of
2019 we made 200 million dollars
right but this year in march in the same
week we made
5 000 99 loss of revenue should they say
you know what
ebitda c we made 200 million dollars
and just add back the 99 loss i agree
with you it's dumb
no it's fraud that's that's my point is
it's not dumb
it's fraudulent they are making things
up and they're trying to present it as
if it's this
accepted thing and unless people call
out the sham
it will be it'll be allowed call out the
sham do you feel better yes
let's go to this sand oh santa phi
whatever the hell this
is do you feel better yes come on okay
good
sanofi drama let me come on here and say
my rants and then we can talk about
whatever
bear thiefs or whatever you got going on
sanofi drama
so let me just tell you what happened so
sanofi is developing a vaccine for
coronavirus
and the eu it's supposed to bring it to
the us
first and france the i think the prime
minister
uh yeah the prime minister of france was
like
absolutely not you're a french company
you're gonna get the vaccine to us
first and then the ceo of sanofi said
well
you know the us government kind of has
the right to it because it's invested
the most and it's kind of taking the
risk
and france is like we can't have this
screw the u.s what do you think should
happen i don't know this is just
ridiculous
i mean if the u.s paid for the
development of the drug they should get
the results right
take the risk get the reward you know
what the us is saying right now what
get money get paid yeah if we invested
the money then we should get access to
the thing that we paid for
right but here's the other thing is this
is going to just further accelerate the
nationalization
of a lot of this stuff then people are
going to start saying why are we why are
we relying on
a french drug maker we should have
people in the united states who can do
this where we can make an investment in
our country to do it
and on top of that also uh there's a lot
of geopolitical ramifications to this
stuff where if people are saying like
you know what uh
i can't understand why we would ever
um uh help another country before ours
it just drives home nationalism over
like more globalism yeah
well i thought it was interesting what
the deputy finance minister said he said
for us it would be unacceptable for
there to be privileged
access to such in such a country for
financial reasons like i see what he's
saying but like that's the whole point
of
having a business in a company yo france
if you want the reward take the risk
yeah why didn't they invest in sanofi
put your money up or shut up like what
are they doing glad you're salty today
yeah and so your eye twitch because in
times of crisis
again it's just everyone all logic goes
out the window it's like
it's like people say hey you know what
plana uh i think that we should develop
something i'm gonna put all the money up
and you aren't willing to do that but
then when it actually gets created you
just step in and say nope that's mine
like what come on i only do that with
snacks yeah snacks
um okay so overreach uh wisconsin
she steals oreos all the time go ahead
overreach i buy them i invest in the
oreos and you eat them
yeah i'm france in that situation
so the wisconsin supreme court has
struck down the state's stay-at-home
order
saying that it's unlawful and
unenforceable
um and that uh asserting that if it was
left in place our state will be in
shambles
yeah oh this is shocking uh they have an
uh non-constant an unconstitutional
order and the supreme court of wisconsin
said
it's unconstitutional you didn't have to
go to the supreme court to figure that
out all i had to do was read the
headlines like
come on you can't force people to stay
at home that it is your constitutional
right
to have freedom of assembly if you take
that away from people you're violating
the constitution
thankfully there's a state supreme court
that's willing to say that i have no
doubt
that some idiot somewhere will appeal
this and it will go
in front of the national supreme court
what do you think that
people who live in wisconsin are called
are called wisconsinites
what how did you know that because i
know people who live in wisconsin and
they
say wisconsinites oh really yeah i i
read the internet whiskonians
wisconians yeah they're not it's not
wisconsin
i guess it's not a food i don't know
that means
do you think that they should strike
down the orders
i i like the people and i'm with the
people but i also don't
want the people to die i know but the
law
says the law of the land the u.s
constitution says you cannot prevent me
from
having freedom of assembly this is my
been my whole problem all along is what
they should have said is
hey this is really bad people are gonna
die
we need you to stay inside please go
inside let's
influence you to stay inside let's try
to motivate you to go inside
the second you say it is it is the law
that you have to be inside
they violate the constitution and that's
where the mistake it's tricky
it's not tricky it's pretty simple you
can't tell people that they have to go
sit inside their homes
guys what do i do he's like real salty
right now yeah
i've never seen you like this it's again
we're just walking through the list of
things
and we're getting to the point wait till
we get to scotty p
we're walking through a list of things
and we're getting to the point in the
crisis
where people start to normalize the
activity right people start to say like
oh of course well of course they make
you sit inside like that's just how it
is
like no it's a violation of the
constitution it the drug right
oh well our people are more important no
no it's capitalism
make an investment get the reward if you
don't make the investment you don't get
the reward first right
ebitda you can't make up finances like
this is not possible i don't care how
bad the coronavirus is you can't make it
up
unemployment get people back to work all
right what's going on with fake or
uh what's this overreach no fake oh fake
me what's going on fake meat
so you know how yesterday we're talking
about or was it yesterday two days ago i
think it was
yesterday we were talking about uh
there's a beef shortage
and i had to make chicken meatballs
chicken bowls chicken meatballs no the
chicken balls
oh my god no they're not no they're
chicken balls why don't you you should
make the chicken balls and then we could
sell them to people why don't you call
them beef balls
because that's not that's just not what
it is they're a meatball everyone knows
meatballs made with beef no but
but chicken balls made with chicken
somebody in the comments said an italian
meatball is made of like
pork and beef and don't let facts get in
the way of a good story
okay fake meat so i'm interested to see
if there's
a like a resurgence no
an increase i don't know resurgence and
i don't think it's a resurgence because
okay a surge in fake meat because
of this normal beef shortage right now
impossible foods which makes plant-based
burgers and pork raised 500 million
dollars in venture capital
live kindly a media site and a stable
alternative food brands raised 200
million why are you laughing
and memphis meats which grows cultured
meat
raised 160 million have you ever had
fake meat yeah did you like it i did but
i really love like real meat so it's
really
hard to eat that because i know that
it's not real and it's like very salty
like you i mean
i feel like fake meat is going to
continue to be a thing and it'll become
more popular over time
not because people make the decision to
eat fake meat it does taste
good but uh well that's debatable
depends on which one you have
uh but what will end up happening is
restaurants will actually start using
the fake meat
and people will eat it and not even
realize they're eating things yeah right
they'll just get incorporated
you know who will not get on the fake
meat train
mcdonald's why because they know it's
all about the offense was it was it
burger king
i think burger king yeah they had
impossible foods i think partnership
mcdonald's ain't getting on that train
well i think it's interesting
why well because this will completely
reshape the meat industry as we know it
no it'll just save animals lives well
exactly reshape the media industry as we
know it
all right speaking of animals what's
going on with scotty p
why oh he's an animal have you ever seen
him go down the floor on a fast break
and
[ __ ] the ball back and just dunk so hard
you think the rim might fall off only
you
i don't even okay do you see the the
my verbose control of the american
language just like literally spit on me
um scotty p or scottie pippen
i had to do p because to save space um
scotty p
is reportedly unhappy about the last
dance
because he says or reports these are
reports i don't actually know what
scotty p feels
in his heart but uh there are reports
that
he's upset at being basically like
called underpaid and frustrated
well was he underpaid and frustrated at
the time but i think
you know now he's like why did you have
to highlight me like that
because he was underpaid and frustrated
everybody hates the truth
if that's how it was at the time you
can't go back and rewrite history just
because you won six championships
yeah just because you won six
championships doesn't mean you can go
back in time and
uh well he's just not happy with how he
was portrayed and the way
other players talked about him etc
what's wrong with that he can be
subjectively unhappy even if the facts
say
otherwise yeah look i'm sorry that he as
a multi-millionaire who got to play in
the nba for 15 years is unhappy
but that's why it's called a documentary
it's not called a
fiction movie all right someone's in a
bad mood today am i wrong
am i wrong jokes and happiness tomorrow
but am i wrong
you're not wrong all right i'm just
saying it's a documentary like i
understand you might not be happy about
the way the documentary comes out but i
feel like
a documentary is supposed to document
the truth right
we're all just documenting the truth out
here polina is shook right now
why why are you so blurry i'm not
yeah you're just blurry like uh no
that's called a good skin
oh do i have good skin uh are you blurry
nah i'm pretty uh pretty non-blurry
i'll make a documentary and show you the
facts and then i'll talk about it
yeah well i'm already unhappy about you
documenting me having bad skin i guess
what does bad skin even mean
all right guys listen today got weird
real fast
uh we appreciate you watching lunch
money uh well while she's trying to get
rich with us let's just try to get our
lunch money right
stay alert out there all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] going on
scotty p's upset companies are reporting
fake profits you're upset
yeah fake meat fake profits everything
in this world is fake and the virus is
raging on
we'll talk to you guys tomorrow